- Football, marriage.
Two forces that have been in opposition
since the beginning of time.
Today we have a man,
Ned, and his wife, Ariel.
And we're going to find out do
you know your favorite thing
more than you know your wife?
(thunder)
I hope he does
or else he'll be in
trouble and I'll laugh.
(playfully dramatic music)
Alright Ned, we're gonna talk football,
we're gonna talk your
wife, you ready for this?
- Yeah, baby, let's do this.
- Do you know football?
- Yes.
- Do you know your wife?
- [Ned] More.
- Ariel, how are you feeling today?
He's gonna get more
questions right about me
than he is about football.
- One, two, three are you feeling ready?
- [Ned] Yes!
- Oh yeah, yeah baby!
Yeah, psych me up.
- [Ned] Yeah, what's up?
- Alright, question number one,
Ned, name five offensive
positions in the NFL.
- Quarterback, running
back, wide receiver,
offensive tackle, tight end.
- Ned, name five of
Ariel's favorite foods.
- Um, uh let's see.
- So olives, breakfast burritos,
- [Host] Not on my list
but I'll let it slide.
- pasta, salad,
- You need one more Ned.
- [Ned] Uh,
- Remember this is
the easiest question that
we have in this stack,
so take your time.
- How 'bout, how 'bout like a dessert?
- Oh Tiramisu.
- Alright.
How many minutes are in a football game?
- Uh, 60 minutes.
- How long does it take Ariel
to get ready in the morning?
- About 45 minutes.
- 20 minutes max.
- That is not true,
(laughing)
that is not true!
- Sorry, we're gonna have to
give you a big red X on that one.
Alright Ned you've got 20 seconds,
name as many starting quarter
backs in the NFL as possible.
Ready, set, go!
Blake Bortles, Tom Brady, Russell Wilson,
Colin Kaepernick, Phillip Rivers,
Ryan Fitzpatrick, Cam
Newton, Matthew Stafford.
- Alright, now you have 10 seconds,
name as many as Ariel's
bridal party as you can.
Ready, set, go!
Oh, Danielle, Carol, Becca,
Annelise, Grace.
Five for five.
Oh, you can't phase me, Zack.
I'm cold as ice.
Ned, name the last two players
featured on the Madden NFL cover.
This past year was Odell Beckham Jr.
and the year before that
it was Richard Sherman,
but more accurately the
entire Seattle Seahawks.
- Describe Ariel's last
profile picture on Facebook.
I remember the one when
we first met really well.
It was her and a giant dog named George.
- Not the question.
- Not the question, okay.
(laughing)
I think it was one from our wedding
when she was like looking at me.
- You're sweating man.
- You guys totally
debowed my emotional story
about our first meeting.
(laughing)
- I'm sorry.
- How many Super Bowl
rings does Tom Brady have?
- [Ned] Two.
- Four.
- Four?
- [Host] Yes.
- (groans) I hate Tom Brady.
Four Super Bowl rings?
- Four. How many rings
does Ariel normally wear?
- Uh two, she wears her engagement ring
and her wedding ring.
- How many times have the
Jaguars made the playoffs?
- (sighs) That's hard.
1996.
(voice in fast forward)
- [Host] So your answer?
- I'm gonna go with six.
- That is (censor beep) impressive.
Not only do you have, you got the number,
you got the years!
- How many times has Ariel
been to a black tie event?
- Uh, that's pretty tough.
We went to one wedding this year.
(voice in fast forward)
I'll say seven.
- What did I say?
- (censor beep) this.
That is correct.
- What year did the Jaguars join the NFL?
- I'm gonna go with 1995
'cause that's when the
official announcement was.
- What year did Ariel
get her first computer?
- I will say, 2000 and three.
- That is correct.
- Oh my God, yes!
Ned, I'm frustrated to report
that you do know your wife
as well as you know football.
So there you go, turns
out Ned knows as much
about his wife as he does the NFL.
Pretty adorable, also
a little frustrating.
Thanks for watching
"Do you know your partner better
than your favorite thing?"
I'm Zack, see ya next time.
(playfully dramatic music)